think it's so difficult for people to
publicly advocate for the problems of
men and boys because victimhood doesn't
work for men the way it works for women
we don't feel sorry for men and rightly
so by the way biologically men are
disposable in the way the women aren't
for the obvious reasons if you have a
tribe of 10 men 10 women you send the
women off to war you're screwed you send
the men off to war one comes back you
can still replenish the population so
men are disposable always will be much
more than women and so we we don't feel
sorry for men in the same way and I not
advocating that we feel sorry for men
because I don't believe that's the
solution to men's problems the solution
to men's problems is for men to be
better what's up mean you know what I
mean look at you this is what your
entire life has spent on bettering
yourself physically emotionally
psychologically mentally you're obsessed
with performance you're obsessed with
being better you're obsessed with being
happier more fulfilled all of these
things it's a pursuit of your own
greatness